♪♪
So, if you're new to the table, this looks a little different in here.
It's because we're in the month of July.
And in the month of July, we give our staff the practice of a salad,
where they get to take a rest and prepare for the next year.
And so, the joy of that for us is we get to have people who don't normally get to lead,
whether it be through music or through preaching.
So, thank you again to Gary and Noel.
So, is anybody here a fan of basketball, reading, or coffee?
Oh, great! You have something in common with our guest speaker tonight.
Yay!
So, we're going to be hearing from Greg Steele.
He and his wife, Tiffany, have been married for 16 years.
They have two cute kiddos, and they have called the table home for about a year and a half.
So, they're thrilled to introduce you to Greg.
Applause
Hey, thanks for being here, everybody.
Especially want to welcome those who haven't been here before or who are watching online.
Because of what was just said, let you know that I'm not the minister.
I'm just a member here.
So, if you are someone who watches online frequently,
you've no doubt noticed the kids who are loud and wild every time we dismiss for kids' worship.
And you've probably wondered, like, whose kids are those?
Where are those kids' parents?
It's me.
I'm those kids' dad.
But my name's Greg. My pronouns are he, him.
And I'm really glad you all chose to be here today.
In 1903, an excerpt from a poem by Emma Lazarus, titled The New Colossus,
was engraved on the pedestal of the Statue of Liberty.
In full, the poem reads,
Not like the brazen giant of Greek fame,
With conquering limbs astride from land to land,
Here at our sea-washed sunset gate shall stand
A mighty woman with a torch whose flame
Is the imprisoned lightning in her name.
Mother of exiles, from her beacon hand
Glows worldwide welcome her mild eyes command
That air-bridged harbor the twin cities frame.
Keep, ancient lands, your storied pomp, cries she with silent lips.
Give me your poor, your huddled masses yearning to breathe free,
The wretched refuse of your teeming shore.
Send these, the homeless, tempest-tossed to me.
I lift my lamp beside the golden door.
The Colossus of Rhodes, the title refers to,
is one of the so-called seven wonders of the ancient world.
It was a 100-foot tall bronze statue of the Greek sun god Helios
that stood on the shore of a port city named Rhodes.
And there was an inlet coming in from the sea
that went between the statue's legs.
So a very imposing presence, right?
It was a symbol of imperial might, of the power,
of one of the strongest nations in the world at the time.
But to the poet, it is not the same kind of sculpture
as the Statue of Liberty.
To the poet, the Statue of Liberty or Lady Liberty
is conceived of as the mother of exiles,
the one who will welcome the poor, the destitute,
the homeless into the U.S.
And you can see this even in the language she uses
to describe holding a lantern by the golden door.
It's almost reminiscent of like an innkeeper
welcoming tired travelers in the middle of the night
or a lighthouse casting a flickering beam across choppy waves
to help the ships get into shore.
So this poet conceives of the Statue of Liberty
and by extension the United States in some ways
as a welcome, a mother of exiles.
And that has maybe never been less true than it is now.
In the United States of today,
everybody who could be described as among
you're tired, you're poor, the homeless,
tempest-tossed is in very grave danger.
Migrants and immigrants who the poem was referring to
most directly originally are in particular danger
of seizure and bodily harm, including deportation,
unlawful detention, and worse.
Everywhere around us there are poor families
losing access to health care or SNAP benefits or both.
There are members of the LGBTQIA community
facing daily harassment
and powerful people working to prepare concentration camps.
On a personal level, my family is really worried
and I would say fearful about the intentions
of the Department of Health and Human Services
collecting information on people with autism.
So suffice it to say there's a lot of people hurting,
deeply hurting, and many of us in this community
have been personally victimized by these injustices.
And look, can we be honest?
Let's name this.
I do not have the experience to talk to this room
about oppression.
I am a cisgender, heterosexual, white man in the United States,
which means I was born as part of the people group
who hasn't been under the boot of oppression
and has instead enjoyed or experienced privilege
in many ways and many times.
Lots of people in our community have experienced
and are experiencing oppression
that I couldn't really fully comprehend.
What I do know is that it hurts
and that we are all hoping for a lamp beside the golden door
or even just a light at the end of the tunnel,
some sign that things will be better,
things could be better in the future than they are now,
that it isn't a permanent darkness.
And that sense of kind of being in a permanent darkness,
I find grows in recent years.
I remember at the beginning of the pandemic,
people started saying these are unprecedented times.
But then we all kept saying it, right?
Like it's always unprecedented.
And for some people, it's become kind of a joke, right?
Like how many historical events am I expected to live through
per year, you know, before something lets up?
And I want to name that,
but even though these are unprecedented times,
in times that are like this,
I find myself reaching out for Jesus.
Jesus was part of the people group
that lived under the shadow of an empire.
It was the empire which conquered the people
who built that 100-foot tall colossus statue.
Those of you who grew up in church
or grew up hearing Bible stories may already know this,
but it bears repeating that Jesus grew up
and lived in a world where Roman soldiers
could force people to carry their baggage,
where the tax collection service could bleed people dry
and funnel all the revenue back to fill the pockets of the empire,
where people could be executed as political dissidents.
Jesus himself was executed as a political dissident.
Now, you're going to stop me and say,
that's all there is to it.
Jesus' death had religious significance.
It was a sacrifice.
It meant more than that,
and I'm not trying to dispute any of that.
All I want to focus our attention on
is that the charge he was tried under
was being a political dissident,
and the posted notice at Jesus' execution
said he was a political dissident.
It said, Jesus of Nazareth, King of the Jews.
So, of course, his death meant much, much more than that.
But one of the things it meant
was that his world was a world where dissidents could be executed.
So in times like our times,
in these unprecedented times,
it's maybe more timely to hear the words and deeds of Jesus
than at any other time.
I think maybe Jesus' message is for unprecedented times,
as we call it.
His people, the people that Jesus was born into,
were not only facing oppression by the empire,
the Roman Empire,
but they were also in the midst of a spiritual crisis of sorts.
There were a lot of different ways,
different ideas about what it meant to be a faithful Jew,
a true Jew.
And some of those ways were really difficult or even impossible
given their setting in the world.
Their society, Jewish society,
was a tiny corner of that huge empire.
And it was part of a cosmopolitan society,
one of the first melting pots,
if you like that phrase or are familiar with that.
And so some ideas of being a good servant of God,
being a good Jew,
included isolationism from non-Jews
that most people just couldn't do, right?
You can't afford to be picky about where your food comes from
if you don't have a lot of money to buy Jewish food.
You can't afford to be particular about working or not working on some days
if you've got to get along, got to get by to survive.
And within the many levels of power and privilege,
Jesus identified that the majority of Jews,
the majority of people that he lived around and knew,
were having a burden imposed on them,
not only by the empire,
but also by the elite of their own society,
the religious establishment such as it was.
That rings true for many of us, I think.
I think many of the members of this community have joined it
because we've seen that Christians and Christianity
can be the force that's oppressing people
who are at the bottom of the social hierarchy in our world.
Like, it's partly because of Christians,
or mostly because of Christians,
that women can't access abortions.
It's partly because of Christians
that there are so many attempts to write bathroom laws
that are intended to hurt transgender people.
Those are examples that come to mind for me.
There may be other examples that resonate more with you,
but I think you get the idea, right?
And, of course, one of the reasons we're here
is because we believe that it's not all Christians.
And we believe that it's not real, true Christianity that does those things.
But that distinction helps to clarify
why our unprecedented times link up with Jesus' time so much.
Because, for us, it's true.
It's not all Christians.
It's not real Christianity that's doing those things.
But it's the Christians that have power, right?
That have political and social clout,
who are part of the lawmaking process,
who are causing those things.
And that was true for Jesus' people, too.
It wasn't all Jews who believed those things
or who were causing the people on the bottom to suffer so much.
But it was the Jews who had power,
the ones who held positions in the temple, the religious center,
who had political and social clout.
His unprecedented times were a lot like ours, actually.
So part of the meaning of what Jesus did and taught
was that it happened in the context of oppression and exploitation.
He and his friends, his family, his people
lived their lives in the face of overwhelming pressure
from the empire and from within, from the temple elite.
In fact, one time Jesus was visiting his hometown
and he was asked to do the scripture reading
during worship service.
And he actually chose a scripture
that was all about proclaiming good news to the poor,
liberation for captives, freedom for the oppressed,
healing for the blind.
And it's sort of informative for what he thought was important
about what he would do,
because he began his remarks about that passage by saying,
today these words are fulfilled in your hearing.
So against that backdrop, in that setting,
Jesus said some words that are recorded for us
in Matthew chapter 11, verses 28 through 30.
He said, come to me, all you who are weary
and are carrying heavy burdens, and I will give you rest.
Take my yoke upon you and learn from me,
for I am gentle and humble in heart,
and you will find rest for your souls.
For my yoke is easy and my burden is light.
There was an idiom in Jewish culture at the time
that taking someone's yoke upon you meant learning from them
or following in their way of life,
a little bit similar to how we might say a mentor
or somebody is going to take you under their wing
or show you the ropes.
And this idiom was most commonly used, right,
in reference to God's law,
that God's law is like a yoke
that's going to teach us how to live.
But in Jesus' mind, it was kind of a perfect metaphor
for himself and his people.
There was a heavy burden, like draft animals plowing a field,
row after row, year after year, they plowed, they plowed,
with that yoke on their backs to guide them endlessly,
but it was tough to bear.
And so Jesus' offer to those people was rest for their soul.
That rest meant welcoming people
who were on the outside looking in of the religious center.
Jesus' offer for them was to belong
as part of the people of God,
to come to Jesus' own table,
to welcome in the people who'd been left out
or kicked out or screened out or forced out.
The burden that weighed them down involved
or included a very specific idea
of what it meant to be one of the people of God.
And the reason that was a burden
is because if you can't fit that very specific boundary,
then you're on the outs in your own society,
an outcast.
And so one of the biggest ways Jesus lifted that burden
was by opening his arms.
He offered rest to everyone,
not just the people with a qualifying burden,
but anybody with a burden.
Indeed, Jesus' welcome was a type of yoke
or a way of taking people under his wing,
as we might say.
He was replacing the heavy yoke
with a different type of guidance.
He welcomes all his listeners
into a way of being guided through the field
that is not based on having
a heavy two-by-four across our back.
It's a light tugging and a gentle burden to bear,
and it's an invitation to find rest.
But what is that rest for us?
Jesus invites everyone to find rest in him
because he is gentle and humble in heart.
And that fills me with some hope,
a restful sense.
Because it means that in the face
of unimaginable oppression,
there is a response that doesn't need anger as fuel.
Even in the face of unimaginable oppression,
there could be a response
that doesn't need anger as fuel.
There's a resistance to injustice
that is gentle and humble in heart.
I find that most days, nowadays,
I wake up in the morning
wishing that there were some way
to make the world right.
Wishing that governments would be forced to do justice,
that people would be made to condemn bigotry,
and so on.
In my heart of hearts,
I respond to the violence
that's used to carry out this oppression
with a kind of violence of my own.
Meeting force with force.
And there is a need to be forceful
when working for justice.
For my part though,
I find that it is a restless way of living
to rely only on that force.
To have that be the only fuel.
It becomes a heavy burden
to always have to have that anger
as the only thing fueling me.
An additional burden,
even adding on to how terrible things are.
Have any of you felt that burden?
But Jesus offers rest for our souls
through learning from Him.
And we're free to learn from Him
because He is gentle and humble in heart.
It might mean that the real rest
is recognizing that compassion
is what can overcome hatred.
That returning hatred with my own hatred
can never undo hatred.
It can only increase that burden on our backs.
In the rest Jesus offers us,
we face the ugliness of our moment in history
with overflowing compassion.
When our souls are at rest,
when we've received that rest,
we're able to remember that courage
shows itself in unyielding love
just as much as in unyielding force.
And I don't know if there are any history nerds out there.
And I'm definitely no expert.
But one thing we've seen a lot of
in the history of the United States
has been the power of unyielding love
more than the power of unyielding force.
In the American Civil Rights Movement,
some of the major moves forward
were made by Ruby Bridges, a schoolgirl
who endured incredible insults and physical violence
to integrate a school.
And Rosa Parks, an older woman
who went through a lot
for refusing to get out of a seat on the bus
after a long shift.
And even the efforts of the suffragettes
to gain women voting rights
happened not because the suffragettes
had weapons to force the polls to allow them to vote,
but because they had a courage
and an unyielding devotion to justice
that brought them through
and that caused the world that we're in now.
Recently, a Superman movie came out
in the last couple of weeks.
I don't know if you've seen it,
but if you do, I want you to remember this
when you hear one line.
During the movie, Superman is talking with Lois Lane,
who is a brilliant reporter
and the two of them have been dating
for like a short while at this time.
And she says, I'm punk rock
and you're, you know, a hokey small town guy.
And then goes on to say,
like he sees the best in people
even though they don't have much of a best.
And Superman says, maybe kindness is the real punk rock.
And that kind of occurred to me
in thinking about this, right?
That the real strength of like,
even a superhero like Superman
isn't that he can just punch people harder.
It's that he can keep on loving,
can keep on being devoted to justice,
can maintain that love, that compassion.
In some ways, I even feel like
that learning from Jesus,
being taken under Jesus' wing,
that is the rest.
As in, the rest for our souls
is what happens in the process
of trying to learn from Jesus.
I haven't found that rest, I have to tell you.
I seem to let being at rest depend too much
on what's going on around me.
And with the way things are right now,
it's hard for me to feel much rest at all
in that way.
But Jesus was able to offer an invitation
to come and rest.
Even as part of an oppressed people group.
He offers the invitation to learn
how to be gentle and humble in heart
even under the most desperate circumstances.
And to find rest in doing so.
I wonder also if part of the rest
Jesus welcomes us to
is also a grace that sets us free
from feeling like we need
to meet violence with violence.
Because as I reflect
on the promise of rest for our soul,
there is a persistent feeling that
the point of that rest,
the purpose of that rest
is not for me to get energy
to do more violence.
The purpose of the rest
is to give me, give us
the energy to fight and resist
in the right ways.
To teach us how to resist.
My daughter is five,
so we recently have to stop calling it nap time
and start calling it rest time.
So like being at rest in our house
is when Hannah is having her rest time.
And when she talks about this,
she often says,
I'm going to have rest time
so I can be full of injury later.
And that means energy.
But that's what's got me thinking
that this rest for our souls
that Jesus is talking about
is not for the purpose of having injury inside us
and spreading that injury after our rest.
It's for filling us with energy
and spreading that energy outside of us.
Jesus stands beside the golden door
with a lamp raised in His hand.
He invites us all
and bids us welcome.
He welcomes all those
who are beaten down and burdened
to come in and rest,
no matter what the burden is.
He seeks out the huddled masses
on teeming shores
that are written about on the Statue of Liberty
and brings them in.
He welcomes everyone who is poor, homeless,
and tempest-tossed.
He stretches out His hands
the people suffering oppression in our world
and to those who have been harmed
by religious figures and institutions
everywhere all over.
He welcomes us in as a host and a guide.
He offers to show us how to live,
to take us under His wing
and guide us in our path.
And we can accept that.
We can trust Him
because we know that He is gentle and humble in heart.
And when we do,
we get welcomed into rest.
Rest for our souls.
Rest that faces even the greatest darkness
with a power, an inextinguishable power.
The power of love for others.
The power of hope.
May you enter into that rest this week.
And may you find rest for your souls.
Thank you, Greg,
for that message of love
and the call to justice
that overflows from rest with Jesus.
Thank you so much.
We are going to now partake in communion
by the table.
We do that here with an open table,
meaning anybody who wants to participate
is more than welcome to.
The way we do it is we form a single line
down the middle starting at the front
working our way back.
You'll notice that there is both red and white.
The red is wine,
and the white is grape juice.
And lastly,
no one will lead you through partaking it.
You can do so on your own.
You can come kneel.
You can go back to your seats.
Whatever you feel like to do.
So,
transition.
This is the table,
not of the church.
not of the church,
but of the Lord.
It is made ready for those who love Him
and for those who want to love Him more.
So come,
you who have much faith
and you who have little.
You who have been here often
and you who have not been here long.
You who have tried to follow
and you who have failed.
Come,
because it is the Lord who invites you.
come to Him.
.